we'll talk about on the optimization of
the long term on this constrained object
thank you bro
the plan is to talk about three papers
that are joined with Shapiro grow and
briefly mentioned one other paper it's
Owens with Chopra and Lee Han so these
papers address different problems but
they're very closely related and I will
mostly focus on you know the definition
and the algorithms and techniques used
which means I will not have much time
for proofs this is probably not a bad
idea considering this is a last talk of
the day and also I must skimp on related
literature hopefully that's pardonable
to the overarching theme of these
problems and these papers is so this is
these are online of course there's a
learning component plus there are
constraints on the sum of outcomes over
the entire time and similarly the
objective is some function of the sum of
outcomes so that's the common theme
I'm gonna start with the online packing
problem instance of this problem is a
packing LP of this form your maximize
this B dot X subject to constraint ax is
single C and X bigger than 0 plus some
local constraints the matrix a the
vector B and C are all non-negative the
columns of this matrix arrived online
how many columns may come at the same
time so each column corresponds to a
decision variable and you need to set
all the decision variables at the time
they arrive and you cannot change them
after that there are also some local
constraints so for instance the local
constraints could look like
okay the sum of all the decision
variables that arrived at the same time
should sum up to one it should be
integral and so on how do we measure the
performance it's a usual comfort of
ratio look at the ratio of algorithm to
optimum algorithm is your reward and
optimum is reward online site here's an
example of this problem add a location
so an add opportunity or it's also
called add impression arrives online and
can be assigned to many advertisers each
assignment generates a different value
enter our global constraint so each
address that has a capacity which is a
total number of impressions assign team
shouldn't be more than some given number
you want to maximize the total value
generated by the assignment this is an
instance of the packing problem the
decision variables corresponding to a
single impression these are the ones
that come online at a time and you need
to set this so they must sum up to one
and they must all you know they must be
integral so you need to assign the
impression to one engine there are many
other examples of this in network
routing crowdsourcing and more general
problems in ad allocation with the
multiple ads on a page and so on
you consider stochastic models so one
stochastic model is a random competition
model so in this model an adversary
picks the entire instance and you know
also the groupings of the columns of a
and the local constraint and so on but
after he does this nature permutes the
order in which this arrived so it's a
random permutation and the and entities
arrive in a random order the optimum is
independent of this order but the
algorithm depends on it so we look at
the expectation of the algorithm over
this order suppose you make additional
assumptions suppose each entry of a row
of this matrix is a factor be smaller
than a corresponding entry in the you
know and C and the other assumption is
that the algorithm knows T so how long
how many times are there so under these
assumptions the result the
state-of-the-art is something like this
you get a computer ratio of 1 minus
Epsilon
as long as this B is bigger than log in
by it's 1 squared this as big roast
larger and Dodgers the computed ratio
tends to 1 the n is the number of rows
of a and C prime is some universe
becomes so these are the kind of results
are known for this we will consider a
closely related model which is called
the ID model here and this is the model
to think of for the rest of this talk so
here there is a probability distribution
supported over what over this set of
columns that arrived together right the
entity that arrives at one time step and
this could be possibly uncountable and
in every time step I sample one entity
from this and present to the algorithm
so this is a set of columns of a or you
know the decision variables that need to
be set and some local constraints and so
on all that algorithm doesn't know this
distribution but it knows T
and I do model it's easy to see that
it's a distribution over random
permutation instances so any algorithm
that works for the random permutation
for instance algorithm that gives this
also works in iid and for all
interesting cases I know the converse is
also true but that's not it here so
these are very closely related
and so here's my related work there's a
whole line of work that you know
eventually got something like this
starting with da my paper with Tom Hayes
then film and hen singer Corolla baroque
need stein Agarwal blank ad my paper
with Camille Jane c1 Wilkins Castle I'm
at all gupta Molinaro and I'm missing
some others so that's my related work ok
so here's a generalization of this
problem which we call online stochastic
convex programming and this gentle
ization is in quotes again you know it's
on line T time steps now in one time
step you see some set s T subset of 0 on
to the N so some sect ok and this is
presented to you and you have to pick a
word a vector in the set you pick V T
and we repeat this here some other set
is given to you you pick a vector what
is your goal goal is to maximize some
function this is a concave function of
the average of all the vectors R to C
and there's also constraint which is
again the average of all the vectors at
U C must be in some set s so think of
this as a soft constraint versus the
hard constraint that was an online
packing and this F and s are given ahead
of things so this is not what you are
learning now the packing is a special
case how is that so what is s T so now
think of when you get a set of decision
variables all possible valid others you
know setting of decision variables and
then look at the corresponding row sums
that result because of this and the
reward that results to whether this this
is your vector so all such possible
vectors is a set s D and so your
objective is just one coordinate that
corresponds to reward and the
constraints are just box constraints
that the average must be within this the
C by T so the packing is a special case
but here when we look at this problem we
look at regret rather than competitive
ratio so the regret is the additives are
just a difference between off- algorithm
and we also need a regret in the
distance in the constraint which is just
a distance from this set so this is a by
criteria okay
so you can see this is very close
related to the packing problem but it's
not quite a generalization because of
two things one is you look at regret
instead of comparative ratio the other
one is this hard with the soft
constraints but nonetheless the
algorithm that we designed for this also
work for that it's easy to specialize
this and you know make sure that
constraints are you know always matte
and convert to regret to complete every
showing from okay again you know why why
do this so going back to add allocation
there are many instances of this kind of
fun you know non packing constraints one
example is diversity constraint so an
advertiser has an ideal mixture of
demographics in mind and no he may not
be able to get this exact mixture but
you can place a constraint that the
actual mixture that he gets should not
be too far from the ideal mixture it
also have nonlinear objective for
instance if you allocate someone and is
there much fewer impressions and it's
capacity then the loss is not just a
missed opportunity but also there's some
long-term impact on such an address also
the loss is some kind of a nonlinear
function and you can have other things
such as you know you have not just a
revenue you have some notion of
relevance clicks and you know all kinds
of things and you might want to maximize
some concave function of this
and similar applications are also you
know arise in crowdsourcing and so okay
so I want to present an algorithm for
this the more general problem and I'm
going to use online convex optimization
as a black box so let me do a quick
review for what is on line connects
optimization is again this is an online
problem
t-time steps here what happens is the
algorithm fix some vector theta in some
domain Delta and after it picks this it
sees a convex loss function is called GT
and then you repeat this many times now
what is loss of algorithm it's just the
GT of theta T and the optimum has the
optimum static theta that minimizes a
loss in the regret is algorithm the
difference between algorithm and optimum
and all you you know keep in mind is
that you create scales of square root
other parameters just forget about that
okay so now I want to use this black box
for online connect subdivision to design
an algorithm for this online stochastic
conic programming right and in fact
think of the case where there is no
constraint there's only this objective F
we're trying to maximize F of the
average of all the vectors are two
picked so how do you do that so the
first step is to initialize this online
convex optimization with domain equal to
the ball of radius L around the origin
now what do you do when you know in time
step T let theta t be whatever the
online connects optimization is playing
now you get the set s T and you have to
pick a V T what you do you just maximize
- the the linear function given by theta
T which is rather minus theta T okay and
you just play that vector so this is
your plate you pick this vector from the
set now you have to run the online
connects optimization the black box so
you need to define the GT the loss for
this and you define the loss this way
you know it's f star of theta minus
theta dot V T so what is this F star
this s star is a French L conjugate okay
so it's defined this way so don't don't
bother if it all looks mysterious what
is happening geometrically so look at
this function f star of theta minus
theta dot VD here we thought of this as
a function of theta for a fixed VT okay
you can switch this you can think of
this as a function of V for a fixed
theta now what is this this is a linear
function of V right
it's just straight a dot V and this is a
linear function that is tangent to f and
a slope minus theta
so what we're doing is linearizing F by
taking tangent with a given slope so
that's what we are doing and we're using
we're just maximizing greedily this
linear function and every time step we
are picking a different tangent and
we're specifying the tangent by
specifying the slope of the tangent so
what we're saying is as long as these
tangent vacuity linear function will
give you exactly no I'm saying that what
the algorithm is doing is it every time
it's picking a tangent to the function
and it's just greedily picking the
vector that maximizes tangent and then
just by staring at it you know this
gives you an interpretation for the f
star this must be the y-intercept this
must be the value L theta at 0 right so
you know this is a geometric this is a
way I think of central duel it's y
intercept of the tangent with a given
slope and you can also think of this as
a primal dual theta as are like dual
variables and what the Osio is doing is
searching over the dual space so why
does this work
I said no proofs but okay this is the
only slide that has proofs and I'm gonna
give you only the very high-level idea
it's very interesting what happens is
there's a switch the value of the
algorithm for the OACP is exactly equal
to the opt for Osio and opt for OACP is
upper bounded by the algorithm for Osseo
so this difference is smaller than this
difference which was a regret for us you
okay so it's it's which I don't know why
it's happening but this is what is
happening right so the first thing is
actually easy to see so what is a value
of the algorithm it's the value of the
function f at the average and using
Finchel duality i can write it like this
this is a minimum over all theta f star
of theta minus theta times this average
and if you just go back and see the way
we define this gts this is just average
of all the GTS this is how we define
this so all the all the GTS have the
same convex component the conex
component is the same f star of theta
only the linear component is changing
okay so when you average them the konnex
content comes out and the linear
comprehend just averages out right so
but this is the optimum so this is a
minimum theta right so the optimum for
oscar is exactly our algorithm okay now
this thing is a little more complicated
and the this thing holds actually only
in expectation the opt for our algorithm
is less than the algorithm what the
algorithm gets Rocio and this is that we
use iid assumption or the random
permutation assumption and so to get
some idea of what's happening so if you
look at the algorithm the oshio
algorithm what it is getting it's
getting this GT of theta T in the
average of those and we can switch this
right so they say I can think of this as
a function of VT at you know this L
theta of T of VT right so now this is a
linear function of meeting and how was
VT chosen VT was chosen to maximize this
L theta L theta T right that was a
definition of VT so I can plug in any
other that's a VT star this is intended
what the optimum chose I can plug in
that and that will only be smaller so
this is actually a point wise but now
when you take the expectation and then
you do some more calculations
you know this is at most optimum because
of you know this uses convex concavity
of F and other things so I'm not going
to go through the sequence of
inequalities but you know this is
believable right so this switch is
happening and and that's why we get you
know the regret our regret is bonded by
regret of of zero and what we get is
essentially something like this we get 1
by square root T regret L is the
Lipschitz constant of the function f and
and see it depends on which norm you
choose if you choose like no measure the
distance in l2 norm you get n log n if
you measure it in L infinity norm we get
log n and so that's why for the packing
problem we can use L infinity norm and
that's why we get this 1 minus epsilon
computer ratio as long as a budget is
log n by epsilon squared so that
corresponds to this square root log n by
T
okay so now I guess the most very simple
the proof is also not so not so
complicated the problem seemed so the
norm comes you know it depends on how
you measure L with respect to what it
taught now basically and also this OC oh
this is a this is coming from what the
regret you can get for OC oh and that
depends on your domain and so on we
define the domain of theta to be the
ball so whether it's the elven ball or
the L infinity power and so on if it
turns out that it's the ball in the dual
norm so if you use L infinity that's a
take a simplex so then you get login
in fact if fsmo structure there is an
even simpler algorithm that gets even
better regret it gets locked key by t
regret and this is called the Frank will
find rhythm and you know this F has to
be smooth I'm not gonna define what
smooth this and the algorithm is very
simple now you don't you just use you
know instead of taking the instead of
saying what the slope is and trying to
find the tangent at the slope just find
the tangent at the current average at
where you are you know in this current
average just look at the tangent to F at
that point and then just use that to
optimize over your set st and you know
that said everything is before and you
get lucky but he regrets and again you
know the proof is not that complicated
but this requires a smooth smoothness
assumption and sometimes you can use a
smoothing operator to convert non smooth
functions to smooth functions so these
are standard things okay so yeah you
switch typically you say that the argues
not much was the note but it could in
this with that regret thing al can be
much better than hoped so in it cannot
happen and then we switch you you lose
this thing demo tape and the talk is
much better enough because you hoped is
a fixed thing in you switcher every time
so for the for regret yes yeah
and here you show whether you switch me
yeah in this case it cannot be Mia yeah
so it is implies it I guess
yeah because it didn't typically I mean
you could get much better of a note
because of these fix and I'll go things
no yes yeah in this case it is showing
that you cannot get much better but this
is a special case of a very great
minimization problem this one so this is
it's a proof that I don't want to go
through the proof in it
I guess this question might be thirty
actual Optima vs. likes comparing to
single single best theta so also this is
in expectation so for this instance of
Osio what you're saying cannot happen in
expectation so the second thing is an
expectation so maybe for some instance
it can happen but in expectation it
cannot happen because we define the
convex functions in a very specific way
that's a good observation
okay so now so I this is a algorithm
when you only had the reward right so
what happens when you have reward and
constraint together so here what we need
to do is we need to combine the reward
and constraint using some parameter
which we call Z and Z is roughly the
rate of change of optimum as I relax the
constraint okay something like that and
if you know Z then what you do is you
can run a separate instance for the
reward it's separate for the constraint
because constrain toxic you just think
of as a reward it's just the distance
from the set it's a negative of the
distance runa said that's a concave
function you run two separate instances
you can use Frank wolf for one and Osio
for weather and whatnot and you just
combine the two you get a linear
function from here you get a linear
function from here this combined the two
linearly using this multiplier to CS a
multiplier and if Z satisfies you know
something like this then then everything
works but you don't know Z so how do you
estimate it so what do you do so you
estimate it and in particular for the
packing problem estimating Z it turns
out to be equivalent estimating op so
you can just look at the first few
samples and I sped up from here and you
only need to solve a single LP for this
and previously all algorithms before
this for solving the online packing
problem they needed to solve LPS
multiple times because they needed very
very good approximation for opt so they
needed a 1 minus epsilon approximation
table because the error went into L but
here the error goes into the second
order term it goes into regret so we
just need a constant fraction of
constant factor approximation to opt so
we can you know do it with much fewer
samples and just solving it once
okay so that somebody for this part is
we gave a very simple algorithm for this
problem very general problem using this
OCU as a black box and essentially same
algorithm works on line packing and it
works so if you look at the analysis it
also gives you the difference between
random permutation and iid although I
didn't touch upon that you can also use
the franco's algorithm if f has more
structure and this also has connections
to black hole approachability so if I
have time I will touch upon that and
just one thing I want to say is Tim
talked about beyond worst case and I
think this is a very good application of
beyond worst case so this was motivated
by practical applications and has a rich
theory and these algorithms are actually
being used by almost all the companies
that run ads so this was exactly you
know in the frame of that Tim said you
know we are doing as well as an
algorithm that's queuing for the
particular distribution but without
buying the distribution will be worst
case over family of distribution
okay so now the second problem so this
problem is called bandits with concave
rewards and connects objectives so this
is very similar to the online the
sarcastic convex programming problem so
but the difference is you don't see the
set from which you're choosing the
vector so the outcome is still the
vector but you don't see the set what is
what you choose is an arm and for each
arm there is some distribution or
vectors so if you pick an arm then you
get a vector sample from this
distribution okay so that's the
difference between how the vector is
chosen so compared to the osep no ACPA
still can be arbitrary in each time step
but here the choices are persistent so
it's the same choice said that you have
this is where the choice set is
different in each time step but there
the s T can be seen ahead of time you
know what you're gonna get but here the
you know you make a choice but the
outcome is stochastic and then there are
many examples I'm gonna skip this so
what's I'll give them again you use the
same framework so you linearize the
function using
Osio or Frank walls but now you don't
have to set so what do you optimize over
but you still you have arms right so you
want to optimize over arms but you don't
know what you're gonna get so what you
need to do is you need to build
confidence intervals and use the most
optimistic choice within the confidence
intervals to pick the best arm that
maximizes this linear function okay and
then again similarly you can combine you
know if you have F and s you run
separate instances for each and then you
can combine and here in this case you
don't need any Z or anything because the
choices are persistent so you get a
sense of the scale of the objective and
the constraint you can just solve a
simple LP and use that or you can even
use something even simpler so that whole
combination aspect isn't come here so
it's easy to combine
and then again we get results something
like in one or square root T so now
we've seen these two different problems
so one in which you see the information
ahead of time you see what choices
you're making ahead of time one where
this is a stochastic outcome and there
is a common generalization of these two
it's called the linear contextual
bandits with bla bla bla bla
okay so it has common aspects on both so
one aspect from osep is you see the
information before making a choice you
see something okay but then the outcome
is still stochastic so how is that so
here again there are K arm now for each
arm you see a context vector this is in
0en and these contexts vectors are drawn
iid but the outcome vector is not the
same as context vector what we know is
the outcome vector is some linear
transformation of the context vector
plus some nice some zero mean noise okay
so that's a stochastic part now how is
this a generalization for osep you just
make the linear transformation be
identity okay and the distribution is
actually the noise is zero and each
vector in your set st is an arm right so
the context is the outcome that was the
osep problem now what about the bandit
problem here the context is trivial it's
not giving you any information so you
just have the arms and then know the the
outcome vectors are some iid toss from
some distribution we don't know okay so
both of these are special cases of this
more general problem
now here the beam goal is to get a
regret that's independent of the number
of arms so it can depend on the
dimension there are two dimensions the
dimension of the context and the
dimension of the outcome but it should
be independent of that how many answer
this because typically we want to apply
this where the number of arms is very
large okay
and so this we can solve only for the
special cases of packing and when
there's only the objective function as
I'll say later on why this is so and we
get again you know kind of fruit T type
regret but we need additional assumption
here we need for instance the budgets be
at least n times T to the 3/4 there as
earlier we only needed n square root e
so this is this problem is more than the
sum of its parts if they're not able to
match the bounds we get for the special
case er so this this is something more
going on so what's the main idea here so
the main thing is we need to estimate
this linear transformation W the matrix
okay but we don't observe samples from W
we observe this Li you know W applied to
some vector plus some noise right and
there's a way to kind of estimate W from
such observations and this use
conference ellipsoids
so now we build confidence ellipsoids
and now for each arm we pick the most
optimistic estimate within the
corresponding conference ellipsoid with
respect to the linear function that we
are optimizing okay so that's the main
idea you can still you know do this
everything works out where things start
feeling is or start getting more
difficult is in estimating opt so in
both OS c p inverse AP for instance you
had full information you know exactly
what came so you could estimate off from
the samples or if you had some kind of
bandit you could do this pure
exploration and estimate op but that
gives you dependence on the number of
arms k
so all requires you to kind of estimate
what happens no matter what action you
picked in the past but how do you do
this without depending on K and we we
give a way to do this what we the way we
do it is we use the first few rounds for
kind of pure exploration and how should
you do pure exploration you should what
you should do is you should pick the arm
whose context vector is closest to the
longest axis of the ellipsoid because
this is the direction of most
uncertainty and if you pick this arm
then that shrinks our ellipsoid you know
in the optimum fashion and using this we
show that we can estimate opt for the
packing case but we don't know how to
estimate this Z parameter in the more
general case in the more general convex
case and this is this is where we don't
know how to this is the reason why this
algorithms don't work more changeable so
if you give me Z everything works but we
don't know how to estimate C so that's
me in difficulty and these are ok so
this is related to black hole
approachability and I'm out of time so I
have to skip the last part the
contextual bandits which is a little
unrelated
okay so
so these are three problems that involve
this learning plus long term constraints
and the main idea was to linearize this
convex functions concave functions and
the constraints and just do greedily the
pick the one that maximizes the linear
function but how do you pick these
tangents so you can either use some kind
of regret minimization algorithms or you
know with more structure you can use
this Frank wolf algorithm to pick this
linear racers and when you have bandit
you need to estimate confidence
intervals or ellipsoids and you also
need to estimate some parameters v or
opt to combine objective and constraints
if you have both some open problems are
so in both the in the linear contextual
case we don't know how to estimate the Z
so we don't know how to extend algorithm
to the most general setting and the same
thing happens with the other problem
that I didn't mention and a slightly
different track of problems is when I I
make a choice that consumes some
resource but it doesn't consume it
forever so here you know think of
packing problems right so you made some
decisions that no consume some resources
and you have some capacity let's done
forever but suppose you make some
choices that consume some resource for a
while they think of servers that are you
know busy for a while that are doing a
job and then the job is done and then
the server becomes empty again and you
can think of similar problems in that
setting and I think that's a very
interesting line of work so
take a few good
general bushes Thank You speaker